Washington the White House is pushing
back on criticism over president Donald
Trump's rally in Oklahoma on Saturday
while the president was reportedly
unhappy with the turnout in Tulsa others
are upset with his comments on
coronavirus testing
Skyler Henry has that story for the
first time in months reporters did not
have their temperatures checked as they
entered the White House White House says
those in close proximity to the
president will still be checked
this comes after President Trump said he
isn't happy about the increasing number
of coronavirus cases in the country what
you do testing to that extent you're
gonna find more people you're gonna find
more cases so I said that my people slow
the testing down please Democrats say
they will ask members of the coronavirus
task force about the president's
statement when they testify before
Congress tomorrow but the White House
says he was joking
that was tongue-in-cheek Democratic
challenger Joe Biden pounced on the
comment tweeting speed up the testing
CBS News has learned the president was
also frustrated and angry at the
attendance at his first campaign rally
since the corona virus outbreak we begin
our campaign and you just want to thank
all of you you are warriors a little
more than 6,000 people showed up for
Saturday's event well short of the
19,000 capacity Trump campaign manager
Brad Parr scale boosted online about
receiving 1 million requests for tickets
that guy who used to be on our show
would have been furious that something
went haywire in my interactions with the
president after the rally on marine 1
with him I checked in with him on Air
Force One and he was in very good
spirits spoke with him again about the
rally yesterday and it got rave reviews
President Trump heads to a rally in
Phoenix tomorrow while Arizona is seeing
a fast growing number of coronavirus
cases Skyler Henry CBS News the White
House